MALE SPEAKER: And
now, please join me
in welcoming Thunder Levin,
the writer of "Sharknado."
[APPLAUSE]
THUNDER LEVIN: Thank you, David.
Thank all of you
for joining me today
for this most
important presentation.
Since the beginning of
history, human society
has been held together by
a common language and frame
of reference provided by the
shared communal experience
of storytelling.
From Neanderthals
sitting around a
campfire, to the
classic Greek plays,
to the commoners
assembling for Shakespeare,
to the works of
Hitchcock and Spielberg
playing for packed
movie theaters,
those shared communal
experiences are
what held our society together.
They gave people from disparate
backgrounds, cultures,
and socioeconomic classes
a common framework
and understanding.
Just a generation ago,
every man, woman, and child
in America was required to
watch the Tonight Show starring
Johnny Carson so that they would
know what everyone was talking
about the next morning.
But as the technological
revolution of the internet
has fractured the way we consume
media, with people watching
what they want, when they want,
where they want, how they want,
that water cooler
moment has been lost.
If half your friends
cover their ears
when you start talking about
Game of Thrones on Monday
mornings because they
haven't seen it yet,
you understand what
I'm talking about.
And with that fracturing,
with that loss of the shared
communal storytelling
experience, and the resulting
loss of a common language, our
society began to break down.
Friends no longer spoke face to
face, or even on the telephone.
Instead, we poked each
other electronically.
People no longer gather
together in groups,
but instead posted
in chat rooms,
without ever truly knowing
who they conversed with.
And conversation itself
became a lost art,
giving way to texts
and emoticons.
And so our civilization careened
toward self destruction.
Into this pre-apocalyptic
decline in July of 2013
came the most
unlikely of saviors.
When a ridiculous TV movie
about a tornado of sharks
premiered on the SciFi channel,
the most surprising thing
happened.
Our society as a whole
ground to a halt,
and billions and billions
of people all over the world
flocked to Twitter
and began to converse.
Our modern gods, also
known as celebrities,
join the conversation.
Such luminaries as Elizabeth
Banks, Will Wheaton,
Patton Oswalt, Olivia
Wilde, Judah Friedlander,
Damon Lindelof, the
producer of LOST,
and even Mia Farrow
and Philip Roth
all tweeted about "Sharknado".
During the initial broadcast,
the Sharknado hashtag
generated over 5,000
tweets per minute.
That night, the movie became
the first shared communal
storytelling experience
of the internet age.
And by the next morning,
the water cooler moment
had been reinvented and society
had a new common language.
Therefore in summary,
I'm sure you'll
agree that I'm not exaggerating
when I suggest what
the humble sci-fi movie
"Sharknado" has saved
civilization as we know it.
Thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, Thunder.
Well, thank you.
It's hard to know how
to follow that up.
THUNDER LEVIN: The
key to "Sharknado"
is that no one ever seems
to know when I'm kidding.
So I like to just--
MALE SPEAKER: So while we
were sitting there watching
the trailer, you mentioned
that that opening scene, which
was cinematically criticized--
THUNDER LEVIN: Yes,
even in our promo,
they pointed out that the
opening scene with the mafioso
had nothing to do with
the rest of the movie.
And that shouldn't
be surprising,
because I didn't write it.
I had one opening shot of a
Mexican fisherman on his boat
looking up at this huge
wave of sharks and saying,
"necessito un barko mas grande,"
which obviously you can tell
is, "I'm going to
need a bigger boat."
And then the wave crashed over
him and the sharks ate him
and that was it.
And it was just one shot.
But when the director
came to shoot it,
this being a low
budget film and all,
he couldn't justify
renting a boat
and going out on the water,
and bringing the whole crew
and spending a day
just for one shot.
So he invented the mafioso
scene sort of on the spot.
And they just-- and I when
I watched the premiere
I hadn't seen the film.
I was watching at the beginning
of the movie thinking, what
the fuck is going on?
MALE SPEAKER: You're going to
edit that out in post, right?
THUNDER LEVIN: Oh,
you didn't tell me
I had to watch my language.
MALE SPEAKER: So how did you
come to write "Sharknado"?
THUNDER LEVIN: You ask that
like it's an odd thing.
It's funny, I had done a film
for the Asylum, the production
company, called "American
Warships," which
they liked quite a bit.
It was one of their more
successful productions.
And so they asked me
what I wanted to do next.
And I had a couple of things.
I wasn't really sure.
And they said we want you to do
this movie called Shark Storm.
And I was like, why?
Haven't we had
enough shark movies?
And so I turned it
down, especially
knowing that the Asylum has a
habit of playing their movies
completely straight.
And I knew with
the budget that it
would have there was no way
it was not going to be cheesy,
and people would laugh
at it instead of with it.
And so I was developing
some other ideas.
And then like a month
later they came back to me
and they said, forget Shark
Storm, it's Sharknado.
And I was like, what do sharks
have to do with the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization?
Because I heard Shark NATO.
And he said, no, no, no.
Sharknado, a tornado
full of sharks.
And I said, oh, well, that's
the most ridiculous thing
I've ever heard of.
And as long as I can
do it that way, I'm in.
And they recognized, despite
never doing tongue in cheek,
that something called
Sharknado pretty much had
to be handled that way.
And so then I just
had fun with it
and never expected
anything to come of it,
or I would have
directed it myself,
because I was originally
attached to direct it.
And then something
strange happened.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so was the--
could I get the screen up here?
Was that response really
overwhelming for you?
Did you have any idea anything
like this could happen?
THUNDER LEVIN: It's
funny, because I
had I had joked with a friend--
after I wrote the script, I'd
finished the script like the
summer before, summer of 2012,
and then went on to
do another project.
Because I directed another film
in the jungles of Costa Rica
at the same time the Sharknado
was being shot in LA.
But I remember joking to a
friend that someday, goddammit,
I'm going to win an Oscar.
And even then all
anyone will want
to talk to me about is this
crazy thing I've written
called "Sharknado."
MALE SPEAKER:
Little did you know.
THUNDER LEVIN:
Little did I know.
We had a hint that something
might be brewing about a week
beforehand.
The commercials seemed to
be getting good response.
And the press was
starting to pick up on it.
I did a really fun
interview with io9
where they asked some
very serious questions
and I answered in the most
serious manner possible.
And then July 4 came
around, and a couple
of friends who had gone to
different July 4 parties
called me up and
said that people had
been talking about "Sharknado."
And it hadn't aired yet.
And I was like, they're
talking about "Sharknado"?
How can that-- and then things
like this started happening.
Yeah, but no, we
thought maybe it might
turn into a little cult hit.
But when it blew up on Twitter
that night it was just surreal.
We had-- nobody expected that.
We went on Twitter
expecting 100 people.
And 10 would be asking
us serious questions.
And 90 would be telling
us how much we sucked.
And that would be it.
And then we tried to
get into the tweet,
and you just couldn't get
in, because there were just
so many tweets coming in.
And then the celebrities
started getting in on it.
And the most surreal
part of the night for me
was trading tweets
with Damon Lindelof,
who was the producer of "Lost"
and also co-wrote "Prometheus."
He's the one who took
Prometheus from being
a true prequel to
"Alien" and turned it
into a not quite prequel.
And so I ended up
trading tweets with him
because he said
that he was going
to write the sequel
to "Sharknado"
and have it done by the time
"Sharknado" was off the air.
And so I countered that I hoped
he would let me be involved.
But I thought the
rather than a sequel,
we should do a prequel,
only not quite.
And he responded touche.
And that just made my night.
MALE SPEAKER: And since then
we've had the nado added--
THUNDER LEVIN: Nado is
added to everything.
MALE SPEAKER: Did you ever
expect there to be a Twerknado?
THUNDER LEVIN: Is there?
MALE SPEAKER: There
is a Twerknado.
THUNDER LEVIN: Well,
depending on who's doing it,
I'd like to see that.
MALE SPEAKER: So how do you
come up with this stuff?
I mean, do you wake up and
say, oh, yeah of course.
I know how to fix that problem.
A guy will jump into a flying
shark with a chainsaw, like--
THUNDER LEVIN: See, you say
that like it's something odd.
It just makes
perfect sense to me.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
give us something--
THUNDER LEVIN: What do you
find illogical about that?
How would you handle
the situation?
MALE SPEAKER: This is why
you're the interviewee
and I'm the interviewer.
THUNDER LEVIN: You know,
people always ask me that.
I don't know, I mean,
I don't do drugs.
I wasn't drunk or
high when I wrote it.
It's a matter of
taking a disaster
movie, a standard
disaster movie,
and following all the
rules of screenwriting.
But when you get
to the point where
people say that's
not believable,
you just keep going,
because it's "Sharknado."
And we could justify
just about anything.
Now I should say that
in the first two films,
and the first 80% of the third
film, everything that happens
is at least
theoretically possible.
Highly unlikely, I'll
give you, but at least
theoretically possible.
Once the sharks went into
space in the third one,
we sort of lost that.
MALE SPEAKER: You could
feel your credibility
kind of went out the window.
THUNDER LEVIN: The thing
is that in the script
for the third one, when the
sharks were blown into space,
they're blown up
with a lot of water.
So when they get into
zero g, each shark
is in a globule of
water floating through.
So it still made sense.
But when the director shot
it, he didn't-- I don't know
whether he made the choice
or the effects department
couldn't do it,
but at some point,
the globules of water were lost.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
a loss for humanity.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah, so it
would have been scientifically--
MALE SPEAKER: But
it makes sense.
THUNDER LEVIN: The
Jet Propulsion Lab,
after the first movie,
the Jet Propulsion Lab
put out an article that was
supposed to debunk "Sharknado."
And all they really
did was end up saying,
well, yeah, it is
possible, we just
don't think it's
going to happen.
MALE SPEAKER: You'd
think those guys would
be working on something else.
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, they
got to do important stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
true, that's true.
Nothing could be more important.
THUNDER LEVIN:
That's what I say.
MALE SPEAKER: So with
this kind of fearless,
over the topness, which is
what I love about the movies,
do you ever, before they
go on, are you ever worried
that the audience kind of
won't come for the ride.
THUNDER LEVIN: Not anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, what
about before the first one?
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah, the first
one, I didn't expect anybody
to watch it.
And then when it blew
up, when we knew we'd
tapped into something, I guess.
And the second one,
we just had fun with.
And SyFy wanted it to take place
in New York, which was great,
because I'm from New York.
And so I got to sort of
play with the whole New York
versus LA thing.
I'm very-- I live
in LA now, but I'm
very cynical about
life in Los Angeles.
And I think that shows
in the first movie.
And so when we
came to New York, I
wanted to make sure it
was the opposite of that.
I wanted to show how the
whole city, you know,
would come together in
the event of a Sharknado.
MALE SPEAKER: As
only New York can.
THUNDER LEVIN: As
And that's kind of
a highbrow thing
to talk about for "Sharknado."
But there is real stuff
behind some of it.
I'll tell you,
when we were first
talking about what
to do in the story,
I had proposed that
we the Sharknado
be heading towards the
new World Trade Center.
And Finn would see this and go,
oh, hell no, not on my watch.
And then the final,
the last stand
would have been
defending the new tower.
And it was decided by
the powers that be,
and I was willing to be
convinced on this, that that
might be a bit touchy.
And so we moved it to the
Empire State Building,
which is more iconic anyhow.
And I knew I wanted
the shark at the end
to be impaled on the spire.
So it all worked out.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
Now you're a huge
Yankee fan, I believe.
THUNDER LEVIN: Fuck yeah.
Oh, you're going to have
to cut that out, too.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, how
did the Mets come to--
THUNDER LEVIN: I
don't know how you're
going to do with the
product placement.
We'll have to blur out the--
MALE SPEAKER: We have
technology for that.
THUNDER LEVIN: I mean, you
guys don't own Coke yet?
MALE SPEAKER: We're focused.
We're focused.
So anyway, so how
did the Mets come
to be featured in "Sharknado 2"?
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah, that
was disappointing for me.
It was supposed
to be the Yankees.
It was written as the Yankees.
The guy who hits the shark into
the bleachers for the home run
was supposed to be Derek Jeter.
MALE SPEAKER: You
couldn't get Derek?
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, we couldn't
get any-- the Yankees said,
oh, hell no.
I mean, I think that's where
the title for the third movie
came from, was the Yankees'
reaction to "Sharknado."
And the Mets said,
yeah, come on.
So what's funny is that
you'll notice there's actually
a little goof when they're
taking the train back
from-- it's not Shea
Stadium-- Citi Field.
MALE SPEAKER: Citi Field.
THUNDER LEVIN: On the 7 train,
it stops at 96th Street,
and that's because
the art department
had been working from
the original script
and had made the
96th Street signs.
And there wasn't
time to change it
when we ended up going with
the Mets on the 7 train.
So yeah, that was too bad.
MALE SPEAKER: That is too bad.
Well, it's Derek's loss.
THUNDER LEVIN: I think so.
MALE SPEAKER: So
I have to ask you.
THUNDER LEVIN: No you don't.
MALE SPEAKER: What is the
origin of the name Levin, which
in Middle English means--
THUNDER LEVIN: No,
no, don't go there.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Means lightning.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yes,
the dark secret
of my family, which
my parents swear
they didn't know when they
named me thunder is that Levin
actually means lightning.
And I found that out to my great
dismay sometime in high school.
Somebody had looked it up
and confronted me with it.
And I was like, no.
MALE SPEAKER:
Before the internet?
THUNDER LEVIN:
Before the internet.
Yeah, they found an
unabridged dictionary.
And I was like,
no, that can't be.
My parents wouldn't
do that to me.
Well, as it turns out--
MALE SPEAKER: So
other than that,
how did your parents
influence your career?
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, I
guess like any good parents
in the '60s and
'70s they told me
I could do whatever
I wanted to do.
And there was no pressure
to go into something where
I might actually make a living.
MALE SPEAKER: They
weren't looking
for a lawyer or a doctor.
THUNDER LEVIN: No, no.
Well, my father
was a journalist.
And my mother was basically
a housewife and a homemaker.
But she was a big
science fiction fan.
MALE SPEAKER: Really?
THUNDER LEVIN: And
that influenced me.
Her father, my grandfather
on my mother's side, which
would be my mother's father,
was one of the founding members
of the British
Interplanetary Society,
along with Arthur C.
Clarke and some others.
So science fiction runs
in the family, apparently.
And so the one show
that she let me
stay up late to watch when
I was a very little kid
was the original Star Trek.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, good taste.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yes.
And so that's where
it started, I think.
Somebody gave me a book called
"The Making of Star Trek".
And again, I was like
knee high to an ant.
And it was way too dry
for a little kid to read.
I'd probably only
just learned to read.
So the first thing I did was I
turned to the picture section.
And I was just old
enough to understand
that I wanted to be
Captain Kirk or Mr. Spock.
And I was just old enough to
understand that I couldn't,
because I was also
watching the Apollo
mission at the same
time, and it was
hopelessly crude and primitive.
And I didn't want
anything to do with that.
But then someone
gave me this book
and I opened it to the picture
section, the very first picture
in "The Making of
Star Trek", and I
think it's still in
print, is a bunch
of studio technicians working
on the bridge of the Enterprise
in their 1960s shirts sleeves.
And suddenly in my
little mind it clicked,
I can work on the enterprise.
And that's where it all started.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
And so you--
THUNDER LEVIN: Are these
cards color coordinated?
MALE SPEAKER: They are
color coordinated by topic.
THUNDER LEVIN: Really?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
THUNDER LEVIN:
That's impressive.
So you come to Google
for this kind of stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: Actually, they're
not quite in the Google colors.
I kind of goofed that.
THUNDER LEVIN: Oh, well,
you're going to get fired now.
MALE SPEAKER: So what was
the first film you really
fell in love with?
THUNDER LEVIN: First movie?
That's a good question.
I don't have a good
answer to that.
MALE SPEAKER: You have a
good answer to everything.
THUNDER LEVIN: Well,
I mean the first film
that really made an impression,
a life altering impression,
was "Star Wars."
But that wasn't the first
movie I'd ever seen.
It wasn't the first movie
that made me start thinking.
There was a movie
called "Silent Running."
MALE SPEAKER: Oh yeah.
Bruce Dern?
THUNDER LEVIN: With Bruce
Dern and these robots.
I'm convinced that's we're
Lucas got the idea for R2D2
was the drones in
"Silent Running."
And "2001."
Yeah, but I mean it
was "Star Trek" on TV,
and then it was seeing "Star
Wars" for the first time.
Because you know, in the '70s,
movies were dark and serious.
Even the comedies were dark.
And "Star Wars"
was the first movie
where you really got to have
fun in the theater, I think,
for a long time.
It was all Scorsese and "Taxi
Driver" and "French Connection"
and I don't know.
And so "Star Wars" really kind
of turned things around for me.
Made it seem-- also, the
publicity behind Star Wars
involved George Lucas so
much that suddenly here was
a guide for an actual career.
Somebody had done this.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh yeah.
THUNDER LEVIN: And so it seemed
like a little more realistic
choice.
MALE SPEAKER: Suddenly it seemed
like you could be George Lucas.
THUNDER LEVIN: Well,
that was the plan.
It didn't work out
quite that way.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, not yet.
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, not yet.
But I mean, they keep making
all these new "Star Wars" movies
now and they're not hiring me.
So, I mean, that
was my original plan
is I was going to
direct Episode Two.
I figured Lucas would
want to do one himself
when he finally came back to it.
But I was going to
direct Episode Two.
That was the career plan.
It didn't work out.
But as it turns out, I probably
should have, because he kind of
screwed things up.
MALE SPEAKER: I you're
watching, this is your man.
So your first--
THUNDER LEVIN: Wait,
where are the cameras?
MALE SPEAKER: They're hidden.
THUNDER LEVIN: They're hidden.
MALE SPEAKER: Your first feature
was "Mutant Vampires Zombies
From the Hood," or--
THUNDER LEVIN:
You've got to pause
before you say "from the hood".
MALE SPEAKER: From
the hood, sorry.
THUNDER LEVIN: It's
"Mutant Vampires Zombies
From the Hood."
MALE SPEAKER: Or
MVZTH for short.
THUNDER LEVIN: Exclamation mark.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
So how did that kind of
play into "Sharknado"?
What did you bring
from that experience?
What did you learn from that?
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, the main
thing about the zombie film
was that we knew we weren't
going to have a lot of money.
And so first I didn't
want to do anything
that we couldn't pull off.
But second, I
wanted to make sure
that if we did do anything
that we couldn't pull off,
and it might look
cheesy, I wanted
to make sure the audience
was laughing with us instead
of at us.
So I make sure to
incorporate humor throughout.
And obviously that was the
same plan for "Sharknado."
But nobody dived into a
zombie and cut their way out.
MALE SPEAKER: There were some--
THUNDER LEVIN: There were
some questionable elements
in that film, if that's
what you're getting at.
MALE SPEAKER: No, no, I
wasn't going to say that.
I was going to say it did
have some unique moments.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah.
Don't let your kids watch it.
MALE SPEAKER: But
also, actually,
when I watched
the trailer again,
it sort of resonated
the gang violence,
and the police brutality
and everything.
And the teaming up of
the police and the gangs.
It kind of resonates with
things happening today.
THUNDER LEVIN:
Yeah, I mean people
don't understand that I'm making
socially relevant commentary
in my films.
MALE SPEAKER: The best
commentary is disguised.
So if you could go
back in time to--
THUNDER LEVIN: I can.
MALE SPEAKER: You can?
THUNDER LEVIN: That's how
I made "Sharknado" a hit.
When it first came
out, nobody watched.
So I went back in
time and fixed things.
MALE SPEAKER: That makes sense.
Well, so maybe you've done this
already, but I'll ask anyway.
So, if you could go back--
THUNDER LEVIN: See now, if
we had planned this properly,
you would have told me
what you're about to say
and I would have started
saying it before you asked me.
MALE SPEAKER: What
a lost opportunity.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah, oh well.
I'm sorry, go ahead.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm going to try
again to ask my question now.
THUNDER LEVIN: I'm sorry.
MALE SPEAKER: So if you could go
back in time to when you first
arrived in LA, what career
advice would you give yourself?
THUNDER LEVIN: Wow.
You know, people now, film
students and wannabe writers
keep asking me for advice.
And I'm really not sure what
the answer is because everything
I did seemed to make sense.
It just took a lot
longer to get where
I wanted to be than I expected.
I don't have any good advice.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, at least
you got where you wanted to be.
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, not yet.
I haven't directed "Star Wars."
MALE SPEAKER: OK, well, close.
THUNDER LEVIN: Working on it.
MALE SPEAKER: So what
other projects are brewing
in the moment of Thunder Levin?
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, I'm
pitching two TV series.
One is a serious,
post-apocalyptic-- not
post-apocalyptic, apocalyptic.
It's the end of the
world is happening
sort of in slow motion.
And my agent has
that out right now.
I've got another series
that's more like "Sharknado."
It's sort of tongue in cheek.
I've been describing
it as "Star Trek" meets
"One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest" in a submarine.
Basically a group of escaped
US Navy mental patients
hijack an experimental
deep diving submarine
and are then the only
people in a position
to save the world
when mysteriously
the surface of the oceans
start freezing over.
And they discover all
sorts of strange worlds
at the bottom of the sea.
And eventually, they
discover that aliens
are terraforming our plan
and they have to save us.
But that takes a while.
MALE SPEAKER: So once again,
staying within the bounds
of the possible.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And I've
heard there's been
talk of a "Sharknado" musical.
THUNDER LEVIN:
Well, I'll tell you,
ever since the
first movie blew up
and we started talking
about a sequel, myself
and the director,
we've both been pushing
to do Sharknado the musical.
My suggestion for the
title for the second one
was Sharknado 2,
The Great White Way.
And they didn't go for it.
And then like right around
when the third movie came out,
the powers that be started
talking about maybe
we should turn this
into a Broadway musical.
And so the director and I
got very excited about that.
And then nothing has
really come of that.
And then about a
week or two ago I
was-- a fellow classmate,
Richard Tucksmith,
appeared out of
nowhere, and said hey,
are you going to this
musical called Shark Attack?
It's the unauthorized
parody of "Sharknado."
And I had not heard about
it, but I got my tickets
and I went.
And it was a staged reading.
They were trying
to get investors.
But this show was great.
I mean, it was funny.
It was well written.
The songs were catchy.
And so I emailed the
powers that be and said,
look guys, if we don't do
our own musical very quickly,
it's going to become irrelevant.
Because if these
guys get to Broadway,
there isn't going to be room
for a real Sharknado musical.
And so we should-- if
we're not doing our own,
we should just license
the title to them
and let them put the
real title on it.
Yeah, so I'd love
to do a musical.
I started in musical theater
in high school and college.
MALE SPEAKER: I remember that.
THUNDER LEVIN: And the material
just lends itself to song.
MALE SPEAKER: To song, yes.
I think that's what everybody
thought when they saw it.
THUNDER LEVIN:
Obviously, and dancing.
And background dancers dressed
up as sharks, spinning around.
I mean, it would be great.
Actually, the one thing I liked
about this shark attack musical
is they took Tara
Reid's character
and made her touching
and sympathetic,
and gave her real
depth, which I had
done in the original script.
Because it was actually kind
of a love letter to my ex-wife.
And it was about how
these two people would
come together and find
out that they still
worked well together, and
they still had that chemistry.
And then I guess when Tara got
cast, that kind of went out
the window.
And suddenly she
became a lot bitchier
and Nova sort of
became the heroine--
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah, so I liked
seeing that in the musical.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I
hope we get to see that.
THUNDER LEVIN: So anyhow, yeah.
If you see Shark Attack
the musical come out,
it will still be
unauthorized, but go see it,
because it was really good.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So were there any scenes,
anything that you really
regret winding up on
the cutting room floor,
literally or metaphorically?
THUNDER LEVIN: There
was nothing that
got on the cutting room floor.
There were scenes that
we couldn't shoot,
that just were clearly
beyond our ability.
In the first movie
there was a scene
where Beverly Hills
was completely flooded.
And they were driving
their car through.
And they ran into this
agent who was on his phone.
And they yell at him, there
are sharks in the streets.
And he's like, no kidding,
you wouldn't believe
this deal I just closed.
And then he gets eaten.
And in the second one,
there was a whole act,
a whole set piece that got
cut, where the wave is washing
over Manhattan, and
Rockefeller Center skating rink
gets flooded.
And they're all thrashing,
trying to get out of the water.
And the sharks are coming in.
And that's when Tara
Reid shows up and says,
hey guys, need a hand?
And helps rescue them.
And then they're in
a boat going down
to the Empire State Building.
And then the boat-- something
happens to the boat,
so Finn finds a
hot dog stand car.
And he turns it upside
down they climb in
and they surf down Fifth Avenue
in this upturned hot dog cart
umbrella.
MALE SPEAKER: Once again,
staying within the bounds
of the possible.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yes.
Yes.
It makes sense.
MALE SPEAKER: So
speaking of cars,
this is a shared
passion of ours,
you wrote a film titled 200 MPH.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: How do you
feel about self-driving cars?
THUNDER LEVIN: I don't
care for the idea.
MALE SPEAKER: I thought
that might be the case.
THUNDER LEVIN: They can
drive my car when they pry it
from my cold, dead hands.
MALE SPEAKER: And
finally I guess
I wanted to-- since you've
both written and directed
and both together--
which of those do
you find more difficult to do?
Which comes easier?
THUNDER LEVIN: Well,
I mean directing
is physically a lot harder.
I mean, you're working
16 hours a day.
The stress is extraordinary.
I've described
directing a feature film
as the most intense
thing a human being can
do short of going to war.
And in fact, a film crew
is organized very much
like an army.
So it's a lot harder.
Writing, you're sitting at home
in your pajamas at a computer.
What's hard about that?
When people start
screwing with your work
and giving you notes
that don't make sense,
that gets a bit challenging.
Now, directing is a
lot harder, but I also
find a lot more fulfilling.
I was supposed to
direct "Sharknado."
And in hindsight,
maybe I should have.
But since it, I've sort
of become re-pigeonholed
as a writer.
Whereas I was always a director
first and writer second.
And so actually, that's
my plan for this year
is to get back in
the director chair.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, on that note, thank you
very, very much, Thunder Levin.
And we'll turn it over to the
audience now for questions.
THUNDER LEVIN: Raise your hands.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think go to the mic.
THUNDER LEVIN: Oh, we
have a mic, excellent.
Oh, and a spotlight.
Hey, you made the big time.
AUDIENCE: For "Sharknado
3," who did you imagine
would play the president?
And how did you feel about
Mark Cuban's performance there?
THUNDER LEVIN: I
loved Mark Cuban.
I thought he was great.
I wanted-- it was a pipe dream,
but I wanted Harrison Ford
to play the president.
That just seemed obvious to me.
And then the director had an
idea that I thought was great.
He wanted Bill Murray.
And the idea was-- I
don't know if any of you
are old enough to remember
the "Saturday Night Live"
sketch where Lorne Michaels
comes on and holds up
a check for $3,000 and asks
the Beatles to reunite,
and he would pay them $3,000.
And they could divide it
up anyway they wanted.
They could give Ringo less.
Whatever.
And so he was trying to get
them to come down to the studio
because he knew they were
all in New York that night
and perform.
And so we were going to
do a YouTube video making
the same pitch to Bill Murray.
Because you know, he
doesn't have an agent.
The only way you get
Bill Murray in your movie
is you call an 800 number.
You leave a message.
And you try and intrigue him.
And he's traveling around--
MALE SPEAKER: For real?
THUNDER LEVIN: Yeah.
He's traveling around the world.
He doesn't even have a
home address, apparently.
And he checks his messages.
And if something sounds
fun to him, he'll do it.
So we thought if
we did this YouTube
video it might get to him and
he might be tickled by it.
But then SyFy wouldn't
let us announce
that we were doing the film,
or that the director and I were
involved until they were--
until their PR machine was
ready to make the announcement.
And by then it was too late.
And so we just started
casting around.
At one point they were
talking about Donald Trump.
And I said, that's
not realistic at all.
And Mark Cuban was actually
cast at the very last minute.
We were shooting in LA.
He was in New York.
They got to him
the night before,
and he said I'd love to do it.
And they said, well,
the only problem is
we need you tomorrow morning.
And he said, that's no problem.
I'll just get on my plane.
And he was there
the next morning.
And I thought he
did a great job.
I asked him at lunch if he ever
thought about running for real.
And he said, no, there
are way too many skeletons
in my closet for that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
THUNDER LEVIN: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh come on,
someone else be brave.
THUNDER LEVIN: Now what made
you choose to go to that mic?
AUDIENCE: It's closer.
THUNDER LEVIN: OK.
But that was already broken in.
AUDIENCE: It's true.
Let's see, so with three
Sharknado movies now,
and there's going
to be a fourth.
THUNDER LEVIN: There is.
AUDIENCE: Do you
ever wonder if maybe
with the space scene
in the third movie
that maybe you've
jumped the shark?
THUNDER LEVIN: OK, from
the beginning people
have been saying
sharks in space.
So I felt like we had to do it.
And people have been saying, we
need sharks with frickin' laser
beams on their heads.
So there's no telling
what might happen.
No, I do I don't think we jumped
the shark for the simple reason
that this is a movie
about jumping the shark.
I'm not convinced
there's anything
we can do that goes too far.
On the first one, when I
was writing the script,
and I would get feedback
from the producer saying,
I think you might be
going a little too far,
I would just respond with
the same one sentence reply,
it's Sharknado, we
can't go too far.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, going once.
THUNDER LEVIN: That's it?
I like your hat, by the way.
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, come on.
Don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask, going back
to your opening remarks,
if you think that-- this
is a serious question.
If you think that--
THUNDER LEVIN: Sharknado
is a very serious business.
AUDIENCE: I know, right?
I wanted to ask if you thought
that the low budget, made
for TV movie had
a permanent place.
And if you sort of
thought that there
could be a cultural phenomenon
like around those again,
or if "Sharknado" was this
unique thing that can--
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, I think
now that it's happened,
people have been trying to
figure out how to replicate it.
And it's too late,
because it's happened.
You've got to do something new.
You've got to do
something different
if you want to have
that kind of impact.
You can't-- I mean, obviously
they've gotten behind it
for the sequels.
But the first one had
almost no marketing.
This was not a manufactured hit.
In fact, one of the reasons that
I think "Sharknado" took off
summer of 2013 is that there
had been a series of big budget,
blockbuster flops
in the theaters.
And people were getting tired
of being force fed these things
and told that this is
the event of the summer.
You must go see this.
I mean, that was the summer that
"Lone Ranger" with Johnny Depp
came out and failed
spectacularly.
So I think the biggest threat
to "Sharknado's" continued
success is them trying
to manufacture it.
And that's a concern,
because we're
trying to walk a
tight rope, I guess,
between getting the
word out and not
making it seem like this is
something you have to go do.
But to recreate that, I think
you need to do something else.
And I don't know what
the answer to that
is, although actually I'm
working on a transmedia
thing that is trying to
accomplish the same thing,
but through a very
different route.
I think it worked
because it was different
and it was unexpected.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
THUNDER LEVIN: And so
once the unexpected
becomes expected, you've got
to do something even more
unexpected.
AUDIENCE: I guess part
of what I'm asking
is like the low budget horror
movie has become a genre now.
So--
THUNDER LEVIN: Well,
it's always been a genre.
AUDIENCE: OK.
THUNDER LEVIN: I mean,
going back to the 1950s
with Little Shop--
or '60s, I guess--
"Little Shop of Horrors."
And then Roger Corman,
you know, was churning out
these B movies.
And of course, Rocky Horror--
I mean it's not really
a horror film-- but "Rocky
Horror Picture Show"
defined what a cult movie was.
And that wasn't a
manufactured thing.
That became a hit several
years after it was released.
There have always
been low budget horror
films and low budget B movies.
And actually, they're
kind of dying out,
because you can't get them
in the theater anymore.
You can't get them on the
shelf at blockbuster anymore.
It's very hard--
It's hard to get anything
on the shelf at Blockbuster.
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, exactly.
But that's sort of my point.
Is it's hard for
something like this
to be found by the audience.
And so SyFy channel has become
almost the only place for it.
Maybe YouTube or
something like that is
going to become a place for it.
But finding anything
on the internet
is very difficult, breaking
through the clutter,
because there's so much stuff.
So the whole industry
is kind of in flux
right now as to how
smaller projects are
going to find an audience.
So I don't know that we
invented anything new,
or reignited-- we
just, I don't know,
we just came along
at the right time.
I mean, an interesting
side note-- actually this
is being recorded.
I'm not going to
talk about that.
Never mind.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think the more they try
to duplicate the success,
the harder it will be and the
less successful they'll be.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
THUNDER LEVIN: So there's
got to be something new.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk more
about the transmedia project
you're working on?
THUNDER LEVIN: Well, if I give
too much away, it won't work.
It's something that's going to
start on Snapchat, probably.
And then we hope it
will catch on and become
either a web series or an actual
TV series, or a feature film.
And we're going back
to a classic radio
broadcasts for inspiration.
And I think I should
leave it there.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER:
That's appropriate,
because I sort of
thought "Sharknado"
was kind of the "War of
the Worlds" of its era.
"War of the Worlds" had that
sudden onslaught of technology.
THUNDER LEVIN: The
beautiful thing
that happened that night
was that it just happened.
Nobody planned it.
Nobody promoted it.
People just saw the
commercial or the trailer
and thought, how
ridiculous is this.
And some of those
people tuned in.
I mean, I'm convinced,
we had millions
of people tweeting about it.
I'm convinced that most of
them weren't even watching
the movie, they
were just responding
to what the few people who were
watching the movie were saying.
I mean, Mia Farrow
and Philip Roth
posted this photo of
them supposedly watching
"Sharknado."
And Mia Farrow tweeted,
OMG, OMG, OMG, "Sharknado."
And as it came out
later, this was actually
a photo they had taken
several days before,
watching something else, or
looking at their computer
or something.
But they thought it was funny
to post it for "Sharknado."
To this day, I don't know
if Mia Farrow actually
watched "Sharknado" or not.
It was just something
that happened,
and that was what was
so great about it.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, that was.
OK, I think on that
note, we'll close.
THUNDER LEVIN: Nobody else?
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very, very much.
Oh, sorry, go ahead.
Please.
THUNDER LEVIN: I got all day.
You're the ones that
have to go back to work.
AUDIENCE: Talking about
how it kind of got
a lot of people
watching live shows,
do think that had any
push to the producers
and the executive
saying that they would
do live musicals on TV, and kind
of the OJ Simpson miniseries
seems to be
something that people
are talking about a
lot that have happened
since your movie came out.
THUNDER LEVIN: Yes, "Sharknado"
is responsible for everything
that's happened since.
I don't know, I mean the live
musical had been happening
before, but I think the
Twitter response to "Sharknado"
opened a lot of people's eyes.
And they saw that maybe
there was another way
to make things happen other than
the traditional method they'd
been using for years.
And the industry is in a
remarkable state of flux
right now.
And nobody's quite
sure how anything
but the giant
blockbuster movie can
be made, because it costs so
much for marketing campaign
to open a movie and to
cut through the clutter.
How do small films
find an audience?
Medium size films, even,
they're not getting made.
And so everybody's trying
to figure this out.
I mean, I have meetings with
producers on a regular basis,
you know, where they'll
say yes, "Terminator,"
and "Predator," and the
original "Highlander,"
great modestly budgeted films.
Can't make those anymore,
because there's no way
to get them to the market.
If that cost $100 million
to market a feature film,
why would you make
a $5 million film?
It makes sense to make
$100 million film.
And so the whole
industry is trying
to figure out a new
workflow, a new method,
for doing something
besides the blockbuster.
Because we've lost the
shelves at blockbuster.
And we've lost
the small theaters
that will show small movies.
And we've lost a way to
bring them to market.
So I think in the
next 10 years there's
going to be a
revolution in how movies
are brought to the people.
And I don't know
what the answer is,
because if I had the
answer, I'd be rich.
MALE SPEAKER: If you had the
answer, we'd try to hire you.
THUNDER LEVIN: OK,
I have the answer.
MALE SPEAKER: I've lined up
an interview slate for you
this afternoon, just
in case you said that.
THUNDER LEVIN: Excellent.
Yeah, so I don't
know if we really
influenced those
live musicals or not,
but I think we did
open some people's eyes
to how to have that shared
communal experience,
because that's what
it's all about.
And it is something that
resonates for people,
and has since the
beginning of time.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
THUNDER LEVIN: They're
coming to get us.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think that's our cue.
Thank you very, very much.
THUNDER LEVIN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]